[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 31 mai bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale sur tv 78 si
vous nous regardez à 18 heures nous
sommes en direct depuis le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tout de suite les titres de cette
émission 624 participants réunis dans
148 équipe le 11e trophée des
entreprises se déroule aujourd'hui à
saint quentin en yvelines pas le départ
a été donné à 17h30 nous ferons le point
tout au long de cette édition et des
épreuves à lille de loisirs et notamment
un défi golfe ont vu la ryder cup
nous entendons avec en invité depuis
oui la ville a déjà organisé ça j'essaie
à 100 pour les véhicules de plus de 3
tonnes cinquante et un policiers lui est
l'aîné vol selon mme merkel ouvre des
barrages filtrants et puis un parcours à
vélo de près de 6000 kilomètres pour
sensibiliser aux changements climatiques
et développer les alternatives le tour
alternatiba se déroule du 9 juin au 6
octobre en france
à cette occasion alternative à
versailles organise son étape ce
dimanche à vélizy villacoublay en direct
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines on retrouve nicolas landry
bonsoir nicolas alors le gros des
épreuves de cette 11e édition du trophée
des entreprises a été lancée sur cette
île de loisirs le départ a été donné il
ya quelques minutes ce nicolas écouter
grégory je suis à l'épreuve
baguet là je suis avec une équipe donc
il va entamer c'est la 1ère équipe qui
va entamer les preuves de radio alors
déjà comment ça s'est passé ce début de
course
on a couru tout droit à droite
non à droite et après ça c'est fini
alors vous venez de finir la course
d'orientation le golfe comment ça c'est
passé la présentation alors le golfe qui
participent à la ryder cup
donc du coup il arrivé premier coup
juste au dessus du filet pourtant pas
facile hein vraiment pas facile parce
que c'était j'ai un peu stressé mais
les épaules et du cou du coup je suis
assez fier de la performance
vous êtes secret l'équipe de quelle
entreprise on vient de herat maîtrise
arch c attrape c'est une entreprise de
lignières c'est surtout un laboratoire
de recherche de r&d et c'est important
pour vous de participer à ce trophée
d'entreprise on travaille tous les trois
ensemble et puis il ya un petit
challenge de la région et puis au sein
de la boîte
merci beaucoup on va vous laisser
repartir parce que vous êtes en tête
donc bon courage à vous voilà grégory et
puis on se retrouve sur mais on se
retrouve plus loin dans cette émission
sous la surveillance bien sûr nicolas de
camille lambert qui est à la caméra tout
de suite je rejoins à la table mais deux
premiers invités pour cette édition
spéciale à mme david
bonsoir vous êtes bénévoles membres de
l'ace montigny le bretonneux golf une
épreuve de golf est proposée sur son
onzième trophée des entreprises on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure et
jean michel fourgous
bonsoir vous êtes le président à l'est
républicain de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines dont qui organise
cette 11e édition du trophée des
entreprises pourquoi mettre en valeur
jean michel fourgous vos entreprises
lors de cet événement parce que on a de
très belles entreprises
à saint quentin c'est une chance
et on fait aujourd'hui accompagner une
agglomération accompagner les
entreprises c'est les aider à être plus
ensemble à travailler plus sans la
connaître les produits du du voisin
plutôt que d'aller acheter à pétaouchnok
s'cusez moi ou à marseille mais j'ai un
conseil mais vaut mieux acheter savoir
que ce produit existe donc ça les a
droit à plus consommée entre eux donc à
à monter le chiffre d'affaires chacun
des entreprises de saint quentin c'est
apprend aussi à avoir envie de faire des
propositions en commun c'est aujourd'hui
le marché international
oui il faut que les entreprises
françaises apprennent encore plus à un
des démontages commun à offrir une offre
donc plus large
donc je dirais que c'est un état
d'esprit que l'on développe à 50 années
d esprit entrepreneurial vous le savez
en plus aujourd'hui on marie la
compétitivité économique et la
compétitivité sportive puisque et saint
quentin la chance d'être a eu la chance
d'être choisi pour des grandes fêtes fin
des grandes manifestations sportives de
très haut niveau
les vaccins sont compatibles avec les
valeurs de l'entreprise à mais ils sont
très elles sont très proches les valeurs
du sport c'est bien sûr être le meilleur
mais en même temps il ya beaucoup de
sport d'équipé où là il faut pas être
seulement le meilleur il faut être celui
qui apporte le plus de valeur ajoutée au
groupe est en fait on retrouve cette
logique aujourd'hui de donc les dans
l'entreprise mais cette manifestation
fait on leur dit ben donc voilà vous
avez une équipe vous êtes dans une
équipe c'est du travail d'équipé
et c'est comme ça qu'on les apprend un
peu plus à gagner il ya un esprit de
gagne à saint-quentin qu'on souhaite
développer vous savez également
on a un projet éducatif très fort
puisqu'on a en charge la de créer la
première université française a 50 ans
oui c'est un état d'esprit un état
d'esprit éducatif fort un économique
et puis sportif avec des traits les plus
grands événements puisque dans quelques
mois vous allez être vus ici saint
quentin va être regardé par plus d'un
milliard de personnes
donc il faut que cet état d'esprit il
existe il faut qu'il qu'il se voit et
ensuite derrière vous avez vous avez
quatre milliards d'individus donc des
jeux olympiques s'est exceptionnellement
on est en éveil jeux olympiques - voilà
en 2024 une ryder cup en septembre
justement à l'occasion de cette ryder
cup une épreuve golf est proposé pour ce
onzième trophée d des entreprises s'est
ainsi une épreuve qui est gérée donc par
les bénévoles de la smb golf and david
healy à 25 tapis installés trois balles
sur chaque tapis un club dit m il y a un
grand filet de deux mètres de haut
il faut envoyer ses trois balles par
dessus le filet c'est réussi
sur son onzième trophée des entreprises
c'est 35 bénévoles de la smb golf et
nice ont mobilisé 35 bénévoles qui sont
mobilisées lé prochain j'en profite pour
parler des prochains événements au
centre commercial
il y aura une fête de gaulle centre
commercial de l'espace 50 ans quand un
sac très bien golts expérience et en
septembre à septembre la fan zone tout
proche de la ryder cup
il y aura la fan zone également au
centre commercial alors ils durent que
qui je le rappelle se déroule du 28
septembre au 30 septembre c'est dans
quelques mois anne david dites nous en
plus sûre sur votre association elle
donne des cours de golf pas seulement
elle assure aussi une sensibilisation
auprès des jeunes sur le boeuf
faisons des initiations il ya des
personnes qui s'y connaissent un petit
peu qu'ils initient et nous nous
orientons surtout vers les enfants en ce
moment dans les écoles nous les faisons
jouer d'accord ils sont intéressés les
jeunes par le golf est ce qu'ils
connaissaient matshiqi leur expliquer ce
qu'est la golf
oui parce que les premières fois j'ai
demandé qu'est ce que la golf n'encaisse
que la ryder cup
certains m'ont dit du foot c'est du foot
non ça a lieu au canada je crois donc
c'est donc la pédagogie à faire il faut
expliquer c'est troisième événement le
plus médiatisé au nombre rappelons le
derrière les appeler la coupe du monde
qui arrive la coupe du monde de football
et les ai expliqué nous l'a donc ce
travail que vous avez mené un travail
depuis février c'est ça ou presque chaud
à peu près 400 enfants par an dans les
écoles et en juillet non c'est pas
joints sur l'open national nous allons
emmener 400 enfants sur le parcours pour
voir les champions joué merci à david
d'avoir été avec nous et merci également
à jean michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines anne david je rappelle que vous
êtes membre de la smb golf et pour
retrouver plus d'informations sur votre
association
j'invite les téléspectateurs à se rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran et les équipes de sodexo
à guyancourt elles étaient mobilisés
aujourd'hui dans un autre événement 750
personnes ont participé au servathon
stop hunger objectifs de cette opération
de collecte alimentaire qui se clôturait
ce jeudi à lutter contre la faim dans le
monde
une chaîne humaine a été réalisée cinq
tonnes de produits récoltés c'est une
demi-tonne de plus par rapport à l'année
dernière et ces denrées vont au profit
des restos du coeur des propos
recueillis par manon varaldo et clémence
tergnier
[Musique]
actualité du jour c'est aussi cette
journée sans poids lourds à poissy les
véhicules de plus de 3 tonnes 5 était
interdite sauf livraison est des
barrages filtrants ont été mis en place
en trois points stratégiques
un mauvaises habitudes prises par les
conducteurs des camions la ville est
devenue une zone de transit à proximité
des autoroutes a13 et à 14 et la
circulation y est devenu difficile le
reportage de camille lambert on est on
est revenue à l'antenne quelques
problèmes techniques ici au vélodrome
nationale je rappelle que nous sommes en
direct ce vélodrome national pour la 11e
édition du trophée des entreprises 624
participants qui sont réunis dans une
centaine d'équipés on suivra tout au
long de cette édition des points complet
on retrouvera nicolas dans le reee pour
des point complet sur ce trophée des
entreprises jacques m'a vite et on va un
peu modifié le déroulé de notre journal
c'est grégory martin bonsoir alors je
vais retrouver le texte mais question
l'interview en tout cas vous êtes membre
de l' alternative à versailles
alternatiba versailles pardon qui
organise ce dimanche une étape du tour
alternatiba c'est de 14 heures à 20
heures on aura l'occasion d'en parler
alors dites nous en plus sur alternatiba
c'est un moment qui est présent partout
en france il ya plusieurs groupes
alternatiba réunis en france exactement
soit alternatiba c'est un mouvement
national qui a pris forme en 2013 avec
la création du premier alternatiba
c'est-à-dire village des alternatives à
bayonne alors bien sûr le groupe s'était
formé un petit peu avant pour toute
cette préparation
concrètement ça prend la forme
finalement de différentes associations
qui vont mettre en avant les
alternatives qui existent sur le
territoire
et puis
c'est une sorte de prise de conscience
citoyenne puisque le mouvement est
vraiment citoyen qui va qui va entraîner
petit à petit la création de différents
groupes locaux dont il ya eu un
alternative à bayonne
qui veut dire vivre en basque citoyens
pour le climat at-il émergé en quelques
années
qui veut dire vivre en basque citoyens
pour le climat at-il émergé en quelques
années
[Musique]
y a pas de risque forcément le bord de
prb
[Musique]
le lieu de la fête
pour une conférence qui nous explique un
petit peu pourquoi est ce qu'ils font ça
pourquoi est ce que il y à cette
démarche de vouloir sensibiliser
localement et ensuite on finit par un
concert de fin avec une journée qui sera
tourné vraiment autour d'ateliers
pratiques que chacun puisse vraiment
s'impliquer dans les différentes
alternatives
alors je précise juste qu'il y avait un
film documentaire qui a été réalisée à
l'occasion du premier tour alternatiba
here in china qui avaient été réalisés
donc par pascal à hennequin et sandra
blondel donc il revient sur sur cette
démarche
une dernière question à quoi vous
attendez-vous pour dimanche qu est ce qu
il ferait que que cette étape soit une
réussite pour vous c'est du monde
j'imagine du monde qui vient à cet
événement c'est bien sûr du monde parce
que l'objectif d'alternatiba c'est de
cette prise de conscience citoyenne
c'est de pouvoir vraiment sensibiliser
des gens qui ne sont pas déjà dans les
mouvements qu'on connaît et de pouvoir
voilà sensibiliser le grand public et
bien sûr météo rendez vous on croise les
doigts et on vérifié tous les matins
merci grégory martin d'avoir été avec
nos jeux rappelle membres du groupe
alternative à versailles et je rappelle
qu'il organise donc ce dimanche une
étape du tour alternatiba rendez vous de
14 heures à 20 heures avait lisier vous
pouvez avoir plus d'informations sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
l'actualité du jour je le disais tout à
l'heure on va pouvoir voir enfin ce
sujet elle se passe à poissy il y avait
une journée sans poids lourd qui était
organisée aujourd'hui les véhicules de
plus de 3 tonnes 5 était interdite à la
circulation des barrages filtrants ont
été mis en place en des points
stratégiques mauvaises habitudes prises
par les conducteurs de camions la ville
est devenue une zone de transit à
proximité des autoroutes a13 à 14 la
circulation est devenue difficile
reportage de camille lambert en contrôle
mal à dori points de contrôle amuse toi
à ce point de contrôle
robert début de l'opération journée sans
poids lourds à poissy vingt policiers
une quinzaine d'élus et bénévoles se
sont retrouvés pour former différentes
équipes mobilisées sur trois barrages
filtrants
pour nous c'est une première il s'agit
d'interdire la circulation des poids
lourds en transit sur la commune donc
sur trois axes principaux
nous allons procéder à un contrôle des
poids lourds qui vont entrer sur la
commune nous allons leur demander s'il
est effectué une livraison sur la glace
sur le territoire communal et si c'est
le cas ils pourront passer si c'est pas
le cas ils seront invités à faire depuis
2014 la ville a déjà verbalisé plus de
2100 poids lourds boulevard robespierre
les équipes sensibilise les conducteurs
de camions comme deux voitures une
priorité pour la commune c'est plus d'un
poids lourds toutes les minutes qui est
ici et c'est 70 % de poids lourds qui
prennent la ville de poissy pour une
zone de transit c'est au-delà même de ce
que j'imaginais
c'est insupportable parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le droit d'être là mais c'est
insupportable parce qu'il ya la
pollution évidemment à la clé et c'est
insupportable parce que sa gangrène
l'autre trafic interne à la ville de
poissy
donc on veut dire stop nous avons
constaté quand même un nette
augmentation de la circulation de poids
lourds en particulier des traverses à
des vitesses quand même assez importante
et pour nous ça devient très très
probable même de rester dans cet
appartement
comme 80% des habitants maurice souhaite
le contournement de la ville de poissy
ce type d'opération devrait être
renouvelée le maire prévoit d'organiser
des assises de la mobilité et du
transport à la rentrée on revient à
saint quentin en yvelines la ministre
des sports laura flessel et et hier
mercredi à guyancourt pour inaugurer le
nouveau sporting de bouygues à la
structure ouverte depuis 30 ans a subi
un profond lifting pour accueillir ses
2500 collaborateurs quotidien les
détails de michael et demi d'euros une
inauguration en grande pompe la ministre
des sports laura flessel s'est rendu ce
mercredi 30 mai au sporting de bouygues
l'occasion pour l'ancien sportif de haut
niveau de découvrir le nouveau visage de
la structure entièrement rénové pour
plusieurs millions d'euros ça donne
envie
mais aujourd'hui j'ai quand même des
talons donc du coup j'éviterai d'enfer
mais c'est vrai que ça donne envie et
puis derrière ce qui est bien aussi
c'est que c'est ouvert aussi au public
donc ça permet aussi de valoriser la
pratique pour tous le lifting comprend
notamment la rénovation des courts de
tennis des terrains de squash chez des
vestiaires une zone d'équipements de
golf a également été créé une vraie
demande de la part des 2500
collaborateurs qui viennent sur le site
quotidiennement et qui trouvait l'ancien
sporting vieillissant après 30 ans
d'existence dans le cadre notamment du
d'un smic est à la mode la qualité de
vie au travail
il est important que nos collaborateurs
puissent bénéficier d'installations de
l'équipe
afin dé festivement venir faire du sport
le midi le soir en toute tranquillité
avec des installations dignes de ce nom
en parallèle de la venue de la ministre
bouygues construction la profité pour
signer un partenariat avec la fédération
dans 10 golf objectifs permet de créer
une école de golf en faveur des
personnes handicapées
le site a également acheté une machine
pour permettre aux pratiquants de taper
la petite balle blanche
autre visite hier sur le territoire au
ski cube celle de la vice présidente de
la région ile de france en charge des
affaires européennes stefan ivanov est
déplacement dans le cadre du joli mois
de l'europe l'incubateur de saint
quentin en yvelines propose un
accompagnement aux pros aux porteurs de
projets il a bénéficié d'une subvention
européenne est d'un peu plus de 330 3000
euros ces fonds sont gérés par la région
ile-de-france interview recueillie par
aurélie rond et nicolas kirillovitch
c'est de faire des projets qui pourront
être financés sur fonds européens qui
peut en bénéficier ce sont les pme pas
les grands groupes et les pme et les
petites donc les petites entreprises les
collectivités territoriales quelle que
soit leur taille
et enfin les associations quelle que
soit leur taille également la seule
l'obligation c'est évidemment d'avoir
son siège sur le territoire la région
ile-de-france à maurepas la nouvelle
aire de jeux de noirmoutier a été
inaugurée hier dans le quartier des
baissière l'espace a été rénové grâce au
deuxième budget participatif de la ville
le concept les habitants déposent des
projets en mairie qui leur tiennent à
coeur
s'ils sont retenus ces projets sont
financés pour ce faire la municipalité
alloue un budget de 150 mille euros
maximum par an un skate park un lieu de
street work out et un hôtel à insectes
ont déjà vu le jour grâce au budget
participatif l aire de jeu elle a coûté
58 mille euros les explications au micro
de clémence tergnier et patrick jacques
de dixmude
nous avons donc installé de nouvelles
aires de jeux notamment un serpent
métallique un trampoline
nous avons mis également en conformité
et rénover les deux petits jeux
existants nous avons également rénover
les sols et clôturée l'air de jeu avec
des barrières métalliques qui permettent
aussi beaucoup plus de sécurité pour les
enfants et aussi pour éviter à ce que
nos amis les chiens viennent y faire
leurs besoins
voilà je vous rappelle que nous sommes
en direct du vélodrome niasse national
de saint quentin en yvelines où se
déroule à côté le 11e trophée des
entreprises ça se tient donc ce jeudi à
saint quentin en yvelines et nicolas
landry que l'on retrouve une dernière
fois nous fait vivre cet événement d'un
peu plus près il est à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines sur le
parcours nicolas vous êtes sur le
parcours actuellement et les trois
équipes m'ont vraiment le potentiel n'a
pas pu emporter
chaque année nicolas vous le voyez donc
les pom pom girls qui viennent dépendent
les couleurs d'elancourt sachet dans une
compétition aussi entre les supporters
merci nicolas on vous laisse profiter de
l'événement d'ailleurs il y aura demain
dans le 7-8 l'hebdo de nicolas kirilow
vite c'est un sujet qui reviendra sur
cette 11e édition du trophée des
entreprises 1 et merci également à
camille lambert aux cadres petit vous
avez sûrement entendu à ces phrases ou à
les raconter vous peut être aujourd'hui
à vos enfants si je bouge la guêpe vam
attaquer les huîtres sont naturels ou
encore les dinosaures ont disparu mais
ces affirmations sont elles vraies hier
après midi à la commanderie des
templiers d'elancourt françois lasserre
qui est un sexologue et vulgariser
vulgarisateur a décortiqué le vrai du
faux un goûter science organisée à
l'occasion de la semaine du
développement durable
camille lambert et mélanie poker je
croyais que c'était j'ai appris aussi
que les pousse à sauter pas dans les
cheveux les idées reçues sur les petites
bêtes qui nous entourent françois
lasserre les décortique ce spécialiste
des insectes invite à réfléchir il animé
hier un goûter science
du conte moi quand je suis devenu grand
moi même que les grands m'avait raconté
c'est justement n'importe quoi sur les
araignées ou sur les bestioles
on manque beaucoup d'esprit critique et
de démarche scientifique
on est un peu irrationnel et avoir
croire qu'une araignée nous a mordu ou
piqué alors que personne n'a jamais vu
faire et que la personnelle n'est pas
arachnologues le point de départ de
l'atelier entre voir l'invisible le nom
de l'exposition temporaire de la
commanderie des templiers
ici l'artiste ma flou et passe doit vous
entraîne dans un cabinet des curiosités
chercher un peu une définition aviv et
donc le cerveau du coup passé beaucoup
l'invisible c'est beaucoup de facettes
c'est ce qu'on voit pas parce que c'est
trop petit trop loin ce qu on s'empêche
de voir ce qu on le voit ce que l'on
voit différemment des autres pour mettre
en pratique les leçons de françois
lasserre sur les petites bêtes qui font
peur mais pas trop il vous emmène en
sortie le 3 juin prochain à magny les
hameaux
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale depuis le vélodrome nationale à
l'occasion du onzième trophée des
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
juste après vous avez rendez vous avec
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat sur la
réforme du baccalauréat
cette édition vous pouvez bien sûr la
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 belle soirée